thanks for joining us America we got cut
off from our guy in Iceland by the
commercials there so let's go back
through that if you are listening to me
in a country that furnishes 100 percent
of your college then you would not need
to save for college obviously you're
paying for that as he said it's not free
you're paying for it with your unusually
high tax rate in a socialistic country
and but that that you know you got free
college or college that you do not have
to cash flow it's come you've already
paid for it in your taxes is what it
amounts to
so university as it is called in a lot
of countries particularly European
countries so yeah you don't have to have
a baby step 5 in that regard you know 7
baby steps baby steps 4 5 & 6 you do
simultaneously for is saving for
retirement 5 is kids college and 6 is
paying off your home early now what I
would do is I would want to know for
college if there are any expenses that
are not covered when you're in
university and if you're at university
and for instance you'll need housing you
need to pay for your own housing because
you travel to a you're not going to be
living at home while you do do
university then you might want to save
up some to cover their expenses that are
not covered by government provided
University but if it's a hundred percent
books tuition housing food I don't know
I don't know what it covers an Iceland
but then you just don't need a baby Step
five is what it amounts to now in a
country where you have a differing
retirement type plans that does not give
you permission to step aside from baby
step four because baby step four is
about you building individual wealth not
to being dependent upon the government
for all of your retirement and
inheritance you want to retire with
dignity wherever you are in the world
and you want to change your family tree
wherever
you are in the world and Lee a godly men
leaves an inheritance to his children's
children wherever you are in the world
and that's going to require building
wealth which is going to require
investing and so your baby step four
will stay the same
you might modify it depending on what
the situation is I you know and what's
furnished and what's not but you know
for those of the United States pretend
that Social Security paid $8,000 a month
instead of $1100 a month okay a
retirement which is dog food money right
but you know pretend you had a fully
funded retirement $8,000 a month you
know that be fully funded for most
people right if the government were
providing that I would still want you to
build wealth beyond that as what I'm
saying because you you know it's not
just whether you can eat at retirement
its building wealth it's changing your
family tree changing your destiny giving
you the options to do things so if you
had an unbelievably healthy retirement
plan furnished from the government then
I still wants you to build wealth so
baby step four doesn't go away but baby
step five could partially or largely or
completely go away depending on what
what of the university is covered in for
it before those of you in Iceland or
anywhere you are that that's the case
and there's a lot of European countries
that that's the case by the way I just
decided no Daniel my son went to Iceland
about 18 months ago absolutely loved it
says one of the best plays best trips
he's ever done if you ever get the
chance to make the visit I've not done
it yet but I probably will just based on
Daniel's recommendation he and some guys
went some buddies of his and they and
completely loved the people the place
says beautiful just incredible the
Northern Lights and so forth I mean just
beautiful beautiful stuff so highly
recommend it now having said that I also
get the other side of this it's like do
you think it free codes they get free
college you mean socialism is awesome
they get free college socialism is
awesome well there's two problems with
your theory one is it's not free because
the tax rate is so freakin high like
we're going I had this happen to Sweden
we were going on a wonderful tour with
this lady going through Stockholm and
she's telling us all the free stuff they
get free stuff this I said I got tired
of it cuz I'm a capitalist
and I finally just said freeze but
what's your tax rate her personal tax
rate was seventy-two percent so freeze
but okay that's the government taking
your money away from you giving it back
to you and making you think you got
something for free okay this is
socialism the other thing you need to
keep in mind is what the gentleman said
Iceland is a wonderful place it is three
hundred forty thousand people it's the
size of Knoxville
that's the GDP okay so it's a little
different economic situation than North
America than the United States of
America okay it's got the gross domestic
product of Knoxville or whatever other
small to medium-sized city that's not
even in our top hundred cities in
America in terms of size and economic
production so again that's not that's
not taking a shot at Iceland but you
just have to keep in mind that when
someone says Sweden has free stuff
Sweden's economy's the size of Dallas
okay so you really if you're gonna if
you're gonna argue economics on these
things on the other side and that
gentleman wasn't I'm certainly not
picking on him and I'm not taking
potshots at this stuff but I'm just
taking potshots at crazy left wingers
who want stuff for free and then
understand what free means okay so you
need to understand that the economic
output of these things is of these
entire countries are don't even equal
one of our major cities in most cases
and certainly in population size to look
at that as well so I mean they've got
some of them have gas reserves or oil
reserves are pulling off the offshore
drilling and other things and so they
got a little different environment
somewhat like a an Alaska or something
where you're getting checks you know
just for living there and that kind of
stuff but but again it's a very small
economic analysis and you cannot use
that to extrapolate and go socialism's
awesome the United States ought to adopt
that no we shouldn't or the more the
largest greatest country in the world
for a reason it's because capitalism
doesn't suck
that's why